okay to people joining this uh live
stream we are looking at the toolbar
candidate for version 13.1
right where do we start
so if you go ahead yeah if you go ahead
and evaluate that and also let me just
make two
uh introductory marks as well so you
know we've already reviewed various
pieces of the tour by ux but
um what we're looking at here is is a
simpler toolbar 31 and then those more
advanced features will you know will
come later
secondly is the point i've made at the
top which is the graphic design review
is underway but it's not yet completed
so what you're looking at the moment
is just what i've put together okay
okay
all right where do i start uh so if you
open up the first section
um i figured we could just
you know we could just go through it
left to right and see if you're happy
with oh i see the toolbar appeared here
yes yeah
um
okay so uh yeah so on the left um i
guess actually maybe first uh you know
resize the window um you can kind of see
how it's laid out um the two
you know the two bits on the left that
is the you've got pins on the left and
right and then the rest stays in the
center
jeremy are you paying attention to this
not yet but i will
and notice when it goes narrow enough
that you're getting uh overflow uh well
yeah
um
oh
okay
so maybe just clip it a bit and you'll
kind of see them disappear um what
you're seeing is the mech is the sun is
the kind of line wrapping mechanism that
we're using but because it's an attached
zone not a dock cell that's why that's
sort of can i ask a question is it is
there any way to magnify the toolbar or
is the toolbar fixed in size
so
it's
difficult to make these sorts of
interfaces
responsive
and
you know always usable
yeah if you understand what i mean
i wonder if the toolbar should have any
mechanism i mean maybe at least a
setting look at least in the notebook
options there should be a setting for
the magnification of the toolbar
that makes sense
would it work for now to set a current
value on the some cell
is that can you
john would that work current value of
cell magnification equals like i don't
know 1.5 uh
you'd have to be able to target the cell
which let's not try to can't have right
now yeah it's right here oh okay oh oh
yeah okay um
yes
current value of cell comma
magnification
symbol magnification
um
equals
two yeah
i'm just gonna say i haven't tried
oh no it's because of all the individual
attached cells no okay yeah
it's close
the cigar was missing but it's close
um
okay all right
my first comment graphic design wise is
i don't like the sort of floatability of
the thing in the middle with all the
space here and maybe there's a way to
deal with that in the design like for
example have this thing be be a somewhat
darker gray with a kind of cut out in
the middle
jeremy your comments or or align or left
aligned that'd be my first option is
just left align it right have some left
some right okay fine
but my my okay so my reason for center
aligning it was because i think central
line toolbars tend to be friendlier and
if you think about the kind of
applications that have them
they're
you know they're things like their pages
or whatever and
that that was the sort of reasoning
behind that um but i'm not married well
i mean we could make it not float as
much by having this area be darker i
think
okay maybe that's wrong jeremy what do
you think i don't think that'll work we
can try it but yeah i'm not confident
that's gonna work okay it's gonna look
odd
okay
all right so let's go from the left yep
so you've got your evaluation pin on the
left um that's basically
by the way should be
shift
uh you know i think that should be in
little keys we've got a shift key and an
enter key and you should say shift plus
enter
you know
in
key things
um
what does that do without a selection
uh is it it's the exact same action as
go as uh shift enter so i think it beeps
actually if you're in between cells
it does
yeah it beeps
but so
why do we have it lit up when you're
between cells
um
we don't have to have it lit up uh
i think given the fact that you know
it's like for example when you evaluate
an input cell you know the insertion
point then jumps between two cells and
so that thing is going to be like
constantly flashing on and off as you're
moving from cells uh and also remember
if you're in like a non-evaluatable cell
but you're just kind of like moving
through a notebook then again it'll kind
of be flashing um but i i think yeah i
mean this is something we're going to
have to look for i think in the overall
design is some
flashing may be unavoidable but i've
that the flashiness is is a non
you know it's it's not an issue you can
just wave away they're they're yeah so
don't flash it
it's okay if you press it and it isn't
applicable
i i think it'd be nicer if it put up a
notifier saying you're not you know
you're between cells rather than just
being a you know mysterious beep so to
speak
well we could put that in the tooltip i
suppose um
[Music]
some some indication
well no i'm saying i'm saying if it
beeps you could put up a notifier
when you press it
does that make any sense oh i see a bit
like a wider beat
by the way
okay
i i sort of think that why the beep
itself might be a bit too
uh
i don't know disruptive um and given
that we don't have precedent for kind of
like
i don't know
notifiers right i mean to my mind the
idea that while you have pressed
something something comes up and says
you're out of luck and if you if you say
oh i didn't see what it said you can
always press it again and see what
happens
right i mean while the button is
depressed
bring up the thing that says you're
between cells it's not going to work
that'd be my suggestion makes sense but
but again i i i'm not right now yeah
okay
so yes okay previously you had said you
know don't put things like uh
notebook context um and kernel status in
the in the toolbar itself and so i've
taken out the bits that i think are most
useful which is localized symbols to
notebook and then potentially parallel
current status however i don't know if
that's hooked up no it's not it would
open you know the parallel kernel of
status dialogue
um however i don't know if you want to
remove that given that i know that
you're not happy with that dialogue
i don't care right now i mean i i think
but graphic design wise
you know that that
down arrow needs to look more
significant because that down arrow is
not
attached to the abort it's its own thing
so to speak
yeah i mean it is it is it's distinct
from a control that is purely a drop
down in the sense that you have a button
and then you have an optional drop down
so it's right that it is in some way
detached does that make sense well i
think that steven's point is uh with the
kind of shades of gray here there's a
risk that if the abort button appear
correctly appears disabled then
one might think the drop down is also
disabled actually let's make a
suggestion that's a good point too but
they make a suggestion
that down arrow really goes with the
evaluate
yes not with the abort so what maybe
what i'm suggesting is
if we have this
that somehow it's the evaluate button
followed by its down arrow because it's
effectively saying
i mean those three are all evaluation
yes
okay what's that one
so well that's it that sets the notebook
that sets the cell context to notebook
it's a so if you click it and
then um
dismiss the dialogue and then open it
again so if you click on the same
chevron you'll see that little tick has
appeared
okay but but all three of these are
evaluate evaluate selected cells
evaluate initialization cells evaluate
notebook
which is i think what they should say
and i think that it should go right by
the evaluation button here
yeah that's fair enough
no does that menu change if an
evaluation is running right so there's a
there's a um if you if you check the
check box that i put there uh it says
evaluation running just beneath the the
data
that kind of simulates what happens you
know
so so the the first of all the abort
button has become dark um but no the
contents doesn't change
add to queue
oh sorry it does yes add to queue yes
also one last thing i'll note is that if
you select some code so for example
double click on attach cell or something
yeah uh
uh
i think you may have to select i'm
basically showing evaluating place so if
you yeah and then if you
so evaluating places a bit what we think
we should do actually is just is always
keep it there but gray it out instead of
having it appear and disappear
if that makes sense yes but i i mean i'm
going to say i don't think this is quite
right because i think
this here
those first three things are are types
of evaluations
and i agree with you should have
evaluate in place
then evaluate you know well evaluate
the first thing is evaluate in place
and then there are those other kinds of
evaluate
and then this localized symbols to
notebook
is its own completely separate thing
okay
i mean like
it could go in the same in the same pull
down but it just it's somehow
cognitively different from these other
things
oh i see so for example if there's
another heading sort of like delimiting
that pop-up into well i mean we do have
a delimiter line there so there's some
indication already of that
um
i think a label helps though it's not
obvious evaluate stops at the line it
might continue but a group yes
evaluation related things
but i think look evaluate selected cells
values initialization spells
um you know i think that's what we
should say by default now what you do
when there's an evaluation going on and
there's an add to queue i don't know how
to deal with that
well and of course you know
we've reviewed
like a very extensive ux for dealing
with that and and this is sort of
necessarily simpler so they can get in
for this one so there's not
there's not a lot we can do
um which is why i sort of ended up doing
nothing which is just to keep it to say
add to cue
fine i just don't think there's
evaluating i think you should say
evaluate
then then just write it out add selected
cells to queue
out of initialization so you know
or no or we could just say no no
actually what we should say is add to
evaluation queue colon
okay right in this case we should just
say evaluate select cells values
initialization cells evaluate notebook
and so on and then we should say
otherwise and this is a you know
temporary hack before we have all the
fancy stuff i'm sorry you're suggesting
that label always regardless of whether
an evaluation is currently running
no i'm not i'm suggesting that label
comes in if an evaluation is running
what it does is it says
um
uh
you know
add to selection queue by the way did
somebody who should have been recording
this did you set that correctly
i'm just asking
project who's who's project management
here
john fultz and uh noah i believe are
handling the note taking the meeting
wasn't recorded at the start so we're
going to handle that after the fact
okay
okay
this will end up getting published in
the live stream
this is currently live streamed okay
okay good so so okay so we'll pick up
the recording from that
um
okay so in any case
um
what i'm suggesting is
that the case where there's no
evaluation going on
okay
and no selection
it should say
here no header just evaluate selected
cells value initialization cells
evaluate notebook
okay okay
then
if there is a selection
that it adds a thing at the top saying
evaluate in place
or evaluate
selection evaluate selection in place
okay yes yep
and then
if there is no selection but it is a
running evaluation
then what it does is it says
add to evaluation queue colon
and then these three things selected
cells evaluation cells notebook so
the
it just seems a bit weird to me the
inconsistency of having a header and one
case and no header i know i know john
this is a hack dealing with the case
before we have the fancy
ui for all of this
okay
and also just one other thing
i'm just surprised that you would prefer
the items to sort of disappear and
appear as they do now rather than
gray out well specifically i'm talking
about you know evaluate selection in
place
no i agree that could gray out okay
okay
um
all right so that's
oh guys
i mean that could perhaps be a slightly
thicker line because it's such a
different kind of concept
or or a heading i mean we could just
find the right heading to go there um
i don't know
i don't know if evaluation properties
it's no that's not really the right
thing um
valuation behavior evaluation
yeah i think it is right that it's
grouped
with evaluation um
yeah it is i mean it's a
if we had more evaluation behavior
options
well actually i suppose is there
anything else that would be useful to
put there
um
run with quiet
that's not very useful
that's an amusing thing to happen now
i mean the main other thing coming out
of the evaluation menu would be
uh turning the debugger on and off but
i'm not sure i would advocate for
showing that here not not at this time
that yeah
it's um
it got washed away with the flood
so to speak i don't know you know it's
it's it's very old anti-delivery
never mind the
um
okay let's keep going and i am
unfortunately going to run out of time
here we are going to have to continue
this
what what um
i just thought it just i can sort of
stretch the rest of the meeting how how
long do we have left
10 minutes 10 minutes okay
um yeah let's just rattle through the
the the
just the content of the middle section
so okay yeah so if you if the insertion
point is between cells then uh which it
is currently then that says insert cell
you click on that
um and then uh
yeah kevin's put together this lovely
thing where if you mouse down over those
you get a preview of what the cell looks
like
so if you mouse that they go
nice
i don't think we need to pedantically
label it cell preview i mean i i don't
know what the um
i suppose we could label it with the
name of the
style i suppose but why isn't this very
similar to the thing that you get when
you do um
uh
the autocomplete thing for styles
well there there
there are a couple issues there um
one is that uh
uh
it can make the menu you start having to
make decisions about do i want the menu
to be giant
potentially or tiny and unreadable to be
faithful to the style or do i need to
start chain you know
modifying things to make them usable
look i think this functionality is great
i think the graphic design is not
perfect the the other issue which i
think is important to point out is that
in this version you get to see the full
decorations
yeah that's nice
i i think this is nice i i think the
word cell preview is a bit unfortunate
i mean yes we could we could just remove
the heading that might be the cleanest
well i understand but i'm asking
if if we have a mechanism a good
mechanism
for sort of indicating this is a preview
oh i understand uh
i
i i guess
if you somehow sort of tied the
graphic design of that to the thing
you're just showing but i
um
i'm not sure uh oh okay okay okay so
that if you there's a there's a bullet
point in toolbar contents that says sell
style and decorations now if you open
that this is not there there are changes
you want to make to this um but it just
gives you an idea of what's going to go
in there okay so it's things for
changing you know the cell margins the
cell frame and the cell frame labels the
cell dingbat and background that kind of
thing but the interface you see there is
not
we want to make changes to that
where's the background sorry what
where's the background get specified uh
yeah yeah it's not here yet that's
it would be great
i suppose and yeah
i would put that at the top because i
think it's the most likely thing to want
to change
indeed indeed
um what does inherited mean from the
style
correct yes yeah or it may even i mean
it could even be from the notebook but
typically from the style well i would
flip these around i would put the custom
first inherited second
but inherited will be the default value
so what
well so um
the
yeah i had thought about that too i
hadn't mentioned it to noah but i was
concerned about the fact that we may
you know the the inherited is nice and
fixed with and everything lines up the
you know the the customizations may be
variable width
so um so write it so align the inherited
on some axis
to the right here yeah yeah that could
be done
but but anyway this was you know this
was just intended syndication we should
we should look at
we should continue okay
these look nice
okay
what's this
um and
these selected cells
yes also what will help is that those
will be grayed out depending on
you know what you can do with the with
the current state of the selection okay
um yeah
okay come on girl
okay
toggling comments
i don't care about that one i think that
one should be much more obscurified
extend the selection i i i think that
you
its utility okay all right fine yeah
i use it all the time i must say the
keyboard shortcuts i use all the time
especially for commenting out options
oh that's nice
that's really nice
trick stand selection i mean that icon
is obscure as hell but i like what it
does
yeah it's difficult to figure out how
you know how to represent it as an icon
i would suggest a set of nested
frame boxes
like you're you're extending something
oh interesting maybe with like an arrow
going through them or something maybe
maybe
i think the cursor is in
incomprehensible there
um
collapse the selected code into an icon
oh that's iconized
yes
i would just sure a little iconized i
would not try and show the dynamics of
the iconization well don't we have a way
of iconizing where we have an
un-iconized we've got the arrows
pointing out for expansion
and it kind of looks like a british flag
it's quite obscure
you know a union jack but yeah yeah
um
i'm just thinking of the general
knowledge question of where the diagonal
parts come from because that's not
england
i said i don't know where the diagonal
parts come from nevermind scotland
i think that icon is not making it
but the concept is great
well and of course you know as part of
the graphic design review
i'm sure you know billy and jeremy
looking at the icons as well so
fine
is that an interpreter is that a
generate no i think that's not interpret
that's
make by the way john there's this bug
with this a lot yeah yeah yeah we're
aware of it yep
okay if we're gonna do this kind of
input stuff what about tech input
as well
right so if you
that is now complicated because so if
you click on the button next to the one
that you asked okay but wait a second i
just i'm just trying to clarify this
button has the wrong words
okay
it should just say
natural language input
or something
are these verbs
we should just say
i can eyes the select i can selection
yeah
so i mean i i fear that people don't
know what that means
like what does what well okay
okay then then we need a way to have a
question mark here
because i don't think we can explain
them words it's just annoying to i i i
get what you're trying to do i just
don't think it's adequate i don't think
what you've got there is adequate if you
have no idea what's going to happen
no fair enough
um i
is there any way to i i don't understand
the ux of whether we can have a move the
mouse down
and um
so i'm gonna go ahead and say i i doubt
for thirteen one yeah i understand that
so then i would just say i can eyes
selection for thirty yeah okay because
because actually then yeah comment
selection itemize selection
yeah okay
extend selection extend selection
exactly and then natural language
right in terms of tech if you click on
the the sort of little group of you know
operators um
it was going to go in there now john
are you still thinking that this is this
pop-up is not going to make it into
one i i i don't see how
okay
so in that case
okay so the pop-up that is open isn't
going in that means the tech button on
the right we could promote into the
toolbar itself however
i i i guess we shouldn't use the tech
icon we should not maybe some dollar
signs
look like it's for buying
you know in-app
notebook purchase
um
we can have a think about that icon
there are other things that i want to
show you before we run out of time okay
all right
that's around the time so okay well let
me quickly show you then the put the
cursor into a text cell or a text data
cell
okay so now we have text controls
like that
yeah what we what should happen actually
is that um
what's the insert code text
why is that braces for that
uh so it's like you know like in mark
down like a code block and i think
uh
kevin has that been implemented yet we
don't want those that's the wrong icon
for it i mean we should it's a good
concept but it's
i mean
that that's in certain inline cell isn't
it
essentially i think that's how we're
going to do it yes
yeah it's a good thing but a bad icon
insert inline cell but insert inline
cell of a specific style yeah i should
think
we have a style called code text too so
careful not to
interact with that
yes i mean is
is that the right style to use actually
i don't remember exactly what code text
was intended for
code annotation it's yeah text to
describe code
oh okay then yeah
probably is open documentation isn't
working but right
there yeah but you've also uh expressed
skepticism before about having any cloud
functionality in toolbar so i mean
i want you think about that if you click
on it
i think there's no problem with that i
think it's nice but the thing that i'm
most concerned about is i want to do a
search in the documentation not on the
free notebook
so that's the thing next to it well
let's just find a notebook no no to the
left
oh i see sorry sorry a search for
document um yes
yes that's what i want and i would love
to have a combo search
that's yeah
combo combo search is a full release
away at least
okay but but we are working on it we
have a ux underway for that you know
what then i would skip find a notebook i
would say finding documentation because
find a notebook if you don't know how to
press command f
you're you know you were living under a
rock for the last 25 years
could you think like a weird admission
in a in a you know in a programming
in a programming environment toolbar it
seems like an odd thing not to have find
well okay but we need find then
go ahead what were you saying jeremy
well could you click that could we
segment
this the find window
and put a you know search documentation
there somewhere we could if we look what
we i suppose
for now
uh
no
um
that's
this is not the time to be asking for
something like that but wait a minute
search documentation are you saying you
can't do search documentation
no we can do search documentation
um
generally it's just saying in the
incoming ux
here
there are either two magnifying glasses
but he's saying avoid two magnifying
glasses by having a pull down
that allows you to select
i don't know i mean maybe maybe that
thing when it opens out to say find it's
gonna have a it could just have two
fields
that's what i was thinking i mean it's
more complicated with options but you
could get those options after you start
your search
so that's the thing i didn't want to
change is to have uh you know two fields
now that's a variation of the fine
dialogue and that's
you know
i see actually you just want to bring up
the fine dialogue that's your point yes
the fine dialogue i mean bring out find
it looks fine bring out the help viewers
fine bringing up a novel interface
please don't ask for that right now
okay all right fine so i guess our
options are we either have
two magnifying glass-ish icons obviously
we'll make them look different or we
just get rid of find a notebook
i think
i think the thing to do is to have
so documentation icon and then
magnifying glass on top of the
documentation so the pure
documentation icon
an icon with documentation with a
magnifying glass on top and then then
maybe a magnifying glass on top of some
kind of notebook icon
what does that one do so so what brings
up the fine dialogue so why are we
having a third icon for the help i mean
because in some places we have an i in
some places we have a book
and now we want a magnifying glass but
what does the magnifying glass over the
book do where does it go it just
oh i see what you're saying i think it
goes to the same place yeah exactly
right so maybe what we want to do then
is for the for the maybe the only
problem is that the magnifying glass the
raw magnifying glass should be a
magnifying glass on top of a notebook to
indicate it's not going to be a help
dialogue helps
but maybe what the other one could be is
to have a little magnifying glass on the
corner of that book
to indicate
um
or or a little i there or something to
indicate that it is searchable because
it won't be obvious to people but once
again why three icons we're not doing
three icons we're doing two icons here
well no no no no in the system we
already have two icons in some places we
have a book and in some places we have
that that's our
yeah that's a different issue i i'm
gonna let you guys resolve that right i
don't know i mean well i'd resolve it by
not introducing a third i could find but
then which icon would you like to use
that
yeah
it can't be the eye on its own right
so i i don't know whether it's a
different book
you know
i i don't know whether it's booked it's
i'd it's you know
um
a book with a wolf
yeah a book with a wolf is a possibility
i suppose um
that might indicate that might be a
useful thing right
it's like
uh when in doubt willfit up
put that on a t-shirt yeah
um
okay i think i have to go here in in
like
infinitesimal amounts of time oh [ __ ]
um
well if you do want to see one more
thing then just one more thing click
click the toolbar so so so so you know
uh drag the narrow the window
not you know just just take off a few
icons don't don't go crazy with it
uh there right now if you click on the
just to show you what the overflow menu
looks like there you go
cool
and then i think if you if you take off
a few more so you'll have to dismiss it
before you there's a bug at the moment
just click in the notebook then then
resize the window again so take off a
couple more okay yeah then click on that
and obviously we then have to wrap again
yeah
cool
yeah okay good
yeah and obviously there's a little
bugginess around here but that'll be
fixed so
this is very nice it's very nice thing i
mean i think there's some graphic design
needed here i think it could be a little
i don't know how quiet it i mean it's
very quiet right now
whether
i guess it should be that quiet so i i
mean notebooks are incredibly minimal
which i think is is possible
you know and that's that was a
deliberate choice
to to make the to make the toolbar that
that sort of i think it's good i think
it's good
i i'm i'm convinced
um
all right but i have to run
unfortunately
so
okay excellent stuff thank you see ya